we've been doing a lot of actions
without it's just Palin trip
well you're practicing them we've been
doing a lot of different clients and
when we have an action between two
integers we gave it a special name Simon
I remember an operation okay operations
now so far we've done our practice now
you know modern is but we've done our
practice on three of them and they're
here on the board what's the first one
edition yeah let's just get all the one
there right addition subtraction
multiplication
Nega multiplication now what that leads
us to is today's lesson which is
division that's a really good thing that
multiplication division together because
they're really multivision division
they're really two sides of the same
coin
okay it's the same idea no this coin is
older it's the same idea but you'll look
at it from two different angles as
you'll see a little more okay so that's
why it's division is kind of the natural
next step to go to the natural now by
the way just before we move off that
each of the operations has a little
symbol that we use for it don't worry
all right
you got your plus sign minus sign yeah
they all multiplies your time side now
through all the division sign the
division symbol with me
okay I think the division symbol was
designed but people like me it's very
literal because you can see what's it
doing
it's literally take your two things and
dividing them okay so that's my plan for
today so this is the division symbol and
that's why it is what it is you can work
out your own what those are now how do
we divide integers well first let's
think about dividing counting numbers
okay and you found you've been doing a
bit of this already so for instance
now let's do a simple one in fact I'm
going to go up to one very soon once one
is on the board okay let's do 12 divided
by 3 now what does it mean before we
actually write down the answer than
number okay what does the operation ask
us to do how would you put it into words
that's a really good one let me write
down Jesus all writes down how many
three movies going into twelve I like
that I bet any other ways that we could
say the same idea but in different
language I'm gonna give you a different
one I'm gonna get groups right so see
I'm trying to divide off this right and
I'm trying to divide it up into groups
now how many groups am i going to divide
it up into so how many groups of three
are in well that's another way to say it
okay are there any other ways we could
say the same idea but with different
language it's always great having
different ways to say the same thing let
me give you one more which if you
remember do you man we said
multiplication right was a short form an
abbreviation of addition right now in
exactly the same way exactly the same
way division is kind of an abbreviation
of subtraction okay so when we get to
you one in a second but any right to
have mind if division and subtraction
have this
relationship how'd I save you something
probably sir how many times many times
can I subtract 3 from 12 do you see that
see what's going on so if I'm thinking
of division kind of like well how many
subtractions are there inside when I go
to 12 ago 9 taking off 3 then 6 taking
off another 3 3 and I've taken off three
lots and then zero I've taken off four
Lots 3 and that's why as you all know
the answers oh okay now one way was your
way different to these yep nice and fast
okay I'm really glad we ended on this
one three x gives 12 okay now can you
see how these last two they're really
important this one shows us that
division and subtraction have a
relationship but this one shows us that
division and multiplication have a
relationship right it's kind of like
asking the question but backwards now
that's so important I'm going to take
this idea and I'm gonna write it in a
new way mathematically but before I do
that I just want to remind you okay some
names to these guys will come back to
you I'm gonna take this sentence
that's probably a bit too far company
but you did yeah yeah 12/3 we okay with
that that's an alright statement okay
but let's go on to what Ford said he's
really on to something
okay if you're not into the green right
talk divided by three is four I can just
as equally say that 12 is equal to 3
times 4 do you see what I did there see
what I say in fact I'd like you to write
that down
thank you 12 equals 3 times 4 okay now
these are the same statement but looked
at from two different sides going on now
like I said let's remember the names
we've got for these we said that last
lesson when you do a multiplication the
thing you get at the end has a name
starts with a pain that would make Matt
so interesting but unfortunately it's
called
one day one day if you ever become like
a message you're gonna teach a little
students ok everyone what about these
two numbers what are they they have they
have names as well it starts with an F
that's right okay now just like we have
the words the names for all the things
happening here for education we're gonna
have a look at the names for all the
stuff over here or division okay now we
learnt one of them the other day we drew
up a table remember that what was the
what was the Andrews don't call after
you define yes a question
well okay now here's something
interesting something strange happened
over here the things you multiply
they're both called fatness that's the
fact that that's a fact okay but here
these two guys they get different names
that's confusing isn't it the names are
very similar I'll teach you this guy on
the front he's called the dividend
dividend you might have heard it that
word in finance it stocks how did them
what dividend to pay and so on okay
where is this guy here the three is
called a divisor the divisor is what
you're breaking it up into groups all
right so I always found this confusing I
could never tell which one was this
which the easiest way to remember all
three together so long as you can
remember all the words is that the words
are in our for medical autumn that's
convenient isn't it okay so if you ever
have trouble remembering you know if
they ask you in a question which one's
the divisor which one's the dividend I
write them out and then I can see
dividends first that's an S thanks and
then questions just way down okay so
there's the